let's
get it
done
yeah
yeah
let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your absolutely
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all what's up y'all welcome
back to river with griffin snoring
yours truly eric griffin
[Music]
i'm back from the honeymoon
i'm dark and lovely we're gonna talk
about that
uh umbrella academy
um the finishing of obi-wan
there was a little bit about the supreme
court ruling
mexican hospitality
um and a bunch of other stuff so is
[Music]
[Music]
yeah son
feeling that energy today because um
voice feeling good coming back from the
honeymoon
before we get started though let's pay
some bills
um
first up i want to say neutral fall you
can grow thicker healthier hair
and support my show only available to us
customers for a limited time get 15 off
at
dot com n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com men with
code griffin
we'll hear more about them later
all right so what's up everybody well um
welcome to riffing with griffin
i'm in a good ass mood just got back
from mexico and
boy my arm's tired um no i'm kidding um
yeah man it was
it was just just let's just get to it
the honeymoon was spectacular this
picture behind me right now for those
that are watching live on youtube and
thank you for watching live on youtube
also please let's subscribe guys
you know what i mean don't forget to
subscribe
and then i'm on twitch daily you know
how that works air griffin gaming on
twitch i'll be twitching after this
probably and then check me out on
patreon too even if you just want to
support
even if i don't do enough content i'm
trying uh but you know sign up for
patreon there too um you know
and just because shout out to my girl my
wife rachel for you know just just for
her just put that out there anyways so
i'm back from mexico i'll tell you where
i went i went on a beautiful honeymoon
in this place playa de la casa an
escarta
resort i believe is what it was
they got this big resort
and they got a riff raff area okay
i'm bougie like that i worked hard for
20 years to get where i'm at so i don't
when i go on vacation i want to go to a
place that's like you know
it's nice it costs money it was
expensive and it is what it is but they
have a big resort so they got a riff
raff area and then they got this like
exclusive adults only
only the people that are staying there
could be there and there's not a lot of
people there and it's beautiful
restaurants and a beautiful setting it
was it was great and we got to go to the
other place too and when i was over at
the other place i was like oh man all
these kids and stuff like that and i was
like i don't want to be around this on a
vacation it just felt too it's too i
don't like being around a lot of people
on vacation okay it is what it is
so we went to this place it was
absolutely gorgeous i'm gonna show you
some pictures and stuff right now so if
you're listening right now
you know listen it's fine i want you to
listen i appreciate the listening on on
the apple uh google
spotify everywhere you're listening to
the podcast thank you very much and
continue to do that please but if you
can also after you listen you can go
view check out on
um
[Music]
on youtube and here at eric griffin
podcast for some reason i couldn't get
rid of my griffin it's so stupid anyways
so this was like just our room so we had
this like pool
next to the like
adjacent to our room it was so great
and then as you can see that the main
picture that i was showing you is like
that it just this like
over pool was over the ocean you know
which was really dope and that's like me
swimming
so i told rachel to go down on the ocean
and then that i'm swimming in like in
the pool that's a pool that i'm in and
they had this thing overlooking the
ocean this like thing so you know and so
this just me that's on our balcony you
know we had like a hammock over the pool
which was like really nice
then there's all my beautiful wife we
were just chilling a lot that's what we
like to do we just really like to chill
that was our thing
you know i had all these matching
outfits that she got for me i mean if
you can see look at that stupid outfit i
have on
it's actually dope i shouldn't talk
smack i really enjoyed it
and then they had all these great little
bars and restaurants you could just go
in because it was all inclusive
you know this is that picture that
you're that's the background of the
thing so that's like the pool and that
little hole right there is like
you know where i was swimming at in that
big and the pool was like really long
pool it was great you know rachel was
just hanging out in a bikini all the
time and her thing and then like this is
the that's part of the pool that
stretches over the ocean then you have
the ocean and we were swimming in the
ocean out there too we had this
beautiful
this beautiful dinner we went to
and it was just us so you had to sign up
for it and then they take you in a car
to this like a park
uh they had like with all kinds of like
you know attractions it you know it you
know it was like
it was like you know
they had animals and a lot of greenery
and it just was this beautiful like pool
with like uh candles in the pool and it
was only us there
um
you know and it was just this beautiful
dinner and yeah anyway so there's like i
didn't want to show too many pictures it
is what it is
so you know and
yeah man it was like really beautiful
and i just want to talk about like the
the mexican hospitality man there's
something about it i'm telling you right
now man
i don't know if
the place
they wrangled everybody was like make
everybody feel special
you go out of your way to make everybody
feel special make everybody feel like
you love your job
uh you you know that you enjoy the
everything about this the culture
everything because it really came across
like that i mean these guys we went to
this one restaurant man and it was like
the waiter comes over and he's telling
us about the restaurant that's all the
food is from northern mexico and and
he's going in about like the northern
mexico and in in his english is it's not
great but he's trying real hard and he
just makes everything sound delicious
and he's just like i've been working in
restaurants for 12 years i lived in the
states and
this is one of the most authentic and i
just like okay
all right you know when every dish that
comes over he's like oh this is from
this and this and that and that and this
is the in the chevy he's telling us all
about the chef and and how many
restaurants the chef owns and
and and like how long the chef's been
working on this menu and and it's just
like so by the time you start eating the
food you feel like damn okay and then
like you know the dude was just so
pleasant and and just
made you feel like you like this was
like you were the most special person in
the world and and we were staying at
like i said a more exclusive area so
there wasn't necessarily a lot of people
in the restaurant anyway they made it
make sure you know you had to have a
reservation and you know and then you
had like it's when the kind of place you
have like a butler you know
it's just like they're texting you all
the time like what time would you like
your room clean do you need anything and
you know it was just like you know it
was great um and then they made
everything pleasant oh my god and the
room was so nice oh my god and just the
ocean
you just hear the ocean all day and
night
and so like the food was just oh man and
then you know when you do all these
all-inclusive they um
you know you don't you know it's like i
could tell that the portions were great
portions
uh you know it's small portions
so i didn't really eat a lot but you
know but you you were full it was the
kind of portions you should have
everything was healthy it was oh my god
and like i say man i don't know if they
had these people's families
held hostage and told them if you don't
make people feel special we're going to
kill your family because it felt like
that important to
every single person that worked there
that we
we were made to feel like this was
we were the most important people in the
world so shout out to escarta escar i
don't know if i'm saying it right and
the people over at playa de la casa
um
that portion of the hotel it was just
great they had teslas so like if they
would take you in a private tesla to the
other area and then and every time you
got in the car even the people in the
car were like hi my name is guzman
and you know i'm here to you know and he
just was talking about you know the
things we got like one guy gave us some
great marital advice i mean it was just
i'm telling you like
they really helped enhance the trip that
mexican hospitality is real okay like
it's hard working pleasant people to be
around and it just was so
lovely
you know i don't know i don't know how
else to
describe it
i don't know how it's described but it
just was like a really
good ass time man it really was
and but some of the places though i
don't know if you ever went to anybody
ever go to a tasting so there was this
like fancy ass tasting
it was an eight-course tasting okay so
you hear that and you go okay eight
courses right
we get in there and the dude is bougie
as hell like he's a foodie
you could tell
he's this slender dude he was like you
know
you know and they had their face mask on
so i don't know what the hell they're
saying sometimes you know
this particular place they made the
staff wear face masks right
um which i think is good protection for
them some people think of that as like
uh like
the people that are not wearing masks
are wrong but i feel like if i'm
if i'm on a place
i'm protecting my staff i look at it
like that but it's all perspective
so but the guy you could tell he's in
like
he's enamored by the chef okay
and and he just everything that comes
over he's like this is
oh and he explains every single thing
like one of the courses was steak
tartare with ant larva
let me say it again steak tartar with
ant larva
didn't like it but it was like a little
it was like a little cup okay
like a like like a like a ice cream
scoop
that was the whole thing all right
every
it seemed to me that
as the courses went on they got smaller
and the utensils got bigger
so the dude brought like a shovel over
you know what i mean [ __ ] for the next
course and you're like oh [ __ ] this is
going to be a big ass thing and then
it's like this big like literally one of
the courses could have been like you
take your pinky and you dip it in a
sauce and then you go
that was course two you know what i mean
like some of the courses were that
little where i was like okay what and
then and they were like a lot of weird
stuff okay a lot of weird stuff
and then and then you have to listen to
their spiel about every single course so
eight spiels
two desserts
um
you know like i said the
so many different types there was
octopus and there was like all this kind
of little things and creams and sauces
we finished the eight courses
and i was starving you hear what i'm
saying starving
i had to go to the room and order a
hamburger that's how hungry i was after
this eight course tasting but it was so
fancy and bougie that i didn't know what
to like didn't know what to say or do
you know just every you know everything
and you feel like you have to try
everything even though it might be like
you know
they make it sound like it's the most
precious most fancy thing in the world
but it could have been like you know
this is some cow [ __ ] covered in
ant semen and and and then he would go
into a spiel about you know the cow
uh was from the the the northern part of
mexico
uh and this particular farm uh the [ __ ]
is cultivated you know and you're just
listening and you're like okay can i
take can i take my little spoonful of
this thing right now man
so that's the only meal where i was like
what
you know what i mean and then like
finish it
starving
okay so had to go
get that man and it just made me start
to think about some things that like
drive me crazy when you go to like
restaurants so this is the [ __ ] and
with griffin
portion of
the show mexican hospitality was great
but like
here's something that gets on me
if you
if you're
with you're a couple and you sit down
and let's say you order some fancy
shrimp
they should bring you
two
or four
not three
you know what i'm saying
it's two you and your girl
and they bring you three shrimp
that's how you break up relationships
because you're sitting here like okay
it's three shrimps
who getting three
who getting one
and do we gotta cut one so it seems fair
or
why am i dealing with this why not just
bring another one
why you why are you bringing this uneven
amount of stuff
this was happening the whole time
three pieces of bread three shrimp
whatever you know it's like even if you
out with like it's four of you or even
if there's three people this is another
let's say there's three people
three people three shrimp okay everybody
getting one shrimp
but don't bring five
cause now two people getting more
or one person's having more than they
should and so everybody's looking at
each other with like a hey man you know
you already had two shrimp why you
having another one you know what i'm
saying like it's like i don't know if
they do this [ __ ] on purpose
but it's annoying
all the restaurants that do this it's
annoying
bring two for two
bring three for three
bring four or
you bring
an even amount for everybody on the
table
so if there's three people at the table
you bring six shrimp you don't break
five
okay you don't bring five shrimp if
there's
six people at the damn table that don't
make no sense either or if there's three
people at the table so if there's four
people at the table you bring four
shrimp you don't bring five because now
everybody looking at that last shrimp
like who gonna have that shrimp
who should have that shrimp why are you
doing that why are you causing turmoil
at the table because of these uneven
portions
they just you know they make intention
for no reason
and rachel or not rachel's super
competitive she is competitive so like
if i
if i order something she's like well i
want that too even if she don't want it
she got to have it so now we got the
shrimp you know and then rachel will do
this thing where she'll eat something
she don't really want to eat
or no no this is what happens the food
will come
i know it's too much food for her and
i'll be like hey can i get some of that
and she's like no this is mine i know
she's not gonna finish it
but i have to wait for her to get to
this point where she takes six bites and
then she's like i'm a fall and there's
so much food left and i'm like why
didn't you just
share it with me in the beginning
because she initially don't want to
share
i think we're both like that so so when
we go to some place and you bring an
uneven amount of food
you mess with people i can't stand that
that's my first of my bitching with
griffin
uh
things
all right
here's another one and this has to do
with rachel too
so
rachel's
taking a picture of me
and i'm like it's like i know it's not a
flattering picture you know what i mean
but she's like oh this looks good it's
not flattering
you know i go hey why are you trying to
embarrass me like this is clearly gonna
be embarrassing if she takes this
picture of me and she'll say back to me
will you try to embarrass me with your
pictures and that is not true
this is all made up in her head
this is what i mean when i take a
picture of her
no matter what picture i take of her and
i put it up on my instagram or whatever
all the comments are like oh man you got
a baddie uh she's beautiful blah blah
blah it's always good compliments okay
it's her that says she makes it bad
like
i put a picture of her and all the
comments where you look good she sees it
and she goes oh my hair
what what are you talking about your
hair looks great
she's always worried about this part
on the top of her head guys i don't get
it can ladies can you explain it to me
in the comments
and guys
and the guys in the comments too have
you ever
in your life
looked at your woman and been like yo
babe
what's up with your part it's looking
like a harry potter
you know
it's the harry potter lightning bolt
not once have i been like oh that part
is off that's all she sees is the part
or she'll be like i look fat
and i'm like woman you like 102 pounds
soaking wet
you know what i mean
it's like she's slender frame but that's
all she still she was so to her i put a
picture up and she's like will you
embarrass me because that picture makes
me look fat where
where does it make you look fat who who
who is looking at this thinking you fat
who
who
you you're the only one that thinks you
look fat but she can put a picture up of
me up where i look ridiculous
like i'm actually fat
you know what i'm saying
the hurt thing is like oh my god you
look cute i'm like no we're not putting
this picture up because i don't look
good
i actually have fat angles it's just
every angle you know what i'm saying i
got like one angle where if i
a certain way you would be like oh griff
looking good
every other angle
i look like
i'm fat
so it's not the same
i don't know why women do this
you know it's like it's them it's in
their head and then we have to be
responsible you know
it's so
it's so ridiculous
[Laughter]
all right
here's another one just another thing i
learned on the trip honeymoon
women don't like you to touch their face
okay
i like but
sometimes it can be like really tender
you know i like to grab rachel's chin
you know what i mean and then give her a
little kid you know you know what i'm
saying she got a nice chin and her you
know i could i got fat fingers so i just
grab her chin it's like a little titty
you know so i'm like ooh
got this little chin titty and now i'm
like
girl and they'll be like it's like
here's what i hate that she does
we could be like in a super tender
moment
like maybe you don't like this
but tell me after this tender moment
like you know we having a moment
you know what i'm saying like you know
we have in this moment right now
i'm in there like girl i love you i'm
saying some tender [ __ ] grab it and then
like in that tender moment she'll be
like ah
don't touch my face oh my god why are
you touching my face are you know i
don't like when you touch my face
then it's like damn moment gone moment
ruined
you know what i mean it's like
she could have easily just been like
babe you know
oh babe i just did my face routine you
know what i mean like it's not it's all
you know what you know what i find that
when you're fighting it's not even about
a fight communication is such a word am
i gonna use right now nuanced
communication is so
nuanced about
so like when you're dealing with an
issue with your significant other so
you're communicating which is such an
important thing communicating
how you communicate is important
one of the mexican hospitality things so
one of the guard the guy is the driver
so he's driving us to this really fancy
dinner and he has he's he says he's been
married he goes let me give you some
advice and he was so pleasant you know
and he was like you know it's like my
wife he says he was like it's how i ask
my wife so he said
my wife you know she gave me some
tortillas
and the tortillas were cold
and he was saying like so one way you
can do it if you say babe the tortillas
are cold
you know what's up with the cold
tortillas and so he said that's not how
you should do it you should ask her for
what you want hey babe
can i have some warm tortillas or can
you warm the tortillas up
so
that's about how you communicate so it's
like communicate what you like or don't
like
how you can because that's how white
people fight in the first place
when you are fighting with somebody it
especially your significant other the
fight could be it could start about it
could start about hey
you know you left the uh the the peanut
butter you know can you please close the
peanut butter jar you keep leaving it
open
now
you start off about that
but it devolves into why are you yelling
at me
why are you always on you know so then
it becomes about how you are
communicating so this guy said you know
you do it with love you know he said
communicate
and communicate with love so he said
you know warm the tortillas
so that's like that's my thing now no
matter what's happening with rachel i go
baby baby baby
warm those tortillas please
and it's just you know what i mean so
that's what i'm saying
she could have warmed the tortillas i'm
grabbing her chin or i'm like or i'm
like putting my hand on her face like
baby i love you
maybe like you know you know you're
putting your hand on the side of her
face because you want to move in for a
kiss
and then at that moment she's all like
don't touch my face
oh my god it was just you know it just
was it just was a it just was a silly
little moment so now we have this thing
now where we we tell each other so
now we use that all the time now
since in the trip since we got back
she'll even say like babe i need you to
warm the tortillas
by doing this you know and so you just
find little tricks and ways to like say
things lovingly
um so you're not so
freaking crazy
all right guys
enough of that
let's um let's get into actually you
know what let's pay some bills
let's pay these bills can you pay my
bills pay my tail upon bills
let's pay some bills and talk about
neutral fall right neutral fall i don't
have a hair problem but i got a lot of
buddies that have a hair problem that
they're losing their hair and they're
looking for a natural way
uh non-chemical way to get their hair
back or you know at least re-energize or
try to get their hair back
and
you know you got to get ahead of the
thinning hair and neutral falls whole
body approach to hair growth no drugs no
compromises
neutral fall is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement
clinically shown to improve your hair
growth thickness and visible scalp
coverage oh scalp coverage that's the
thing because even for me i feel like
right here i'm getting to the point so i
might have to like actually
test this out myself
but
it's physician formulated using natural
medical grade ingredients neutral falls
drug-free patented technology provides
consistent reliable results without
compromising your sexual health
because isn't that the point of even
wanting to keep your hair is to still
feel sexy and you know what i mean
imagine if you getting your hair growth
but then something's going on down there
in a clinical study men showed
progressive improvement in hair growth
and thickness after three and six months
neutrophil is also trusted and
recommended by more than 3 000 top
doctors
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
nutrafall.com men and entering promo
code griffin to save 15 off your first
month subscription this is their best
offer anywhere and it's only available
to us customers for a limited time plus
free shipping every order get 15 off at
nutrafall.com
spelled n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l
dot com slash man promo code griffin
start growing that hair back today
okay everybody
uh once again thanks for being here uh
riffing with griffin um
okay so what is some stuff that i wanted
to talk about today uh
let's just start it's light and it will
go heavy
um even though this one for some might
not even be
light so i saw
while i was out there in my little
downtime i was able to watch netflix
because i when we vacation we chill i
straight up i don't like doing things i
was like chilling with that ocean so
that's what i was doing so i watched um
umbrella academy
okay
so i don't know if you guys watch
umbrella academy i think it's a pretty
good show i love sci-fi magic
alternate universe type of stuff and
umbrella academy is that umbrella
academy is about like um
it's like this group
some babies are born mysteriously all
over the world and this eccentric
billionaire
buys up a bunch of them
it's like seven of them and he
turns him into superheroes because they
all have supernatural powers and he has
a superhero academy called the umbrella
academy uh this is in the third season
this is the third season it's the third
season so it was starring ellen page and
ellen page turned into elliott page and
so what do you do when one of your main
actors you're pretty much one of your
stars is uh goes into some you know into
transition how do you handle it they
handled it
i'm just gonna talk about how they
handled it you know what it's it was
fine
i'm one of these people that i don't
care
okay i don't care i'm not super right
i'm not super left
i'm i'm kind of one of these people that
like whatever you're gonna do do i don't
really care it doesn't really bother me
uh i think when you're online and you're
like you know
the the online left and the online right
these people make everything so
important and make it seem like we're
supposed to be sitting around really
thinking about this at nauseum and
i will honestly say we really don't you
know when somebody says hey i'm gay my
response is so you know i don't care you
know what i mean i think a lot of us are
like that uh if you're one of these
people that still really cares about
that i always wonder why
why
it's like you know they somebody will
write a comment and they'll be like
uh you know somebody will be like oh
you're oh this is gay okay what does
that mean
you know what i mean like
finish it finish your thought nobody
wants to finish their thought when they
say that because then they even
themselves
they hear how stupid and hateful it
sounds i don't know man i'm just telling
you how i feel i don't care all right
but they make us care by how they talk
about everything at nauseum even now in
my own damn podcast i'm talking about it
at nauseam they dealt with this they
just the character just
hey i've always
you know i've always been this and they
changed from vania to victor and then
they made every character in the show
kind of give it like i don't care i
don't care i'm fine with it happy for
you so they just kind of dealt with it
and for me i wonder though like i
actually would have enjoyed if one of
them didn't like it like if they wrote
that into the show but i kind of feel
like they didn't want to deal with it
you know there's a part of them was just
kind of like hey you know what why don't
we make everybody supportive even though
to me it felt false because this family
isn't supportive
if you watch umbrella academy you know
all they do is bicker and fight and talk
[ __ ] about each other but for this
subject all of a sudden everybody's a
one big happy family so i get it
i feel i understand the choice
probably also for elliott page to be
like hey i kind of don't want to deal
with what i have to deal with in real
life so can we just like do this
transition and then then move on with
the show so i think they they had a
moment i thought they dealt with it like
great you know what i mean i thought you
know i was like okay they kind of just
like everybody loved it and then and
then they just moved on with the show
which i thought what else are they gonna
do
artistically
i would have liked a couple of them to
be like nah
like she's actually fighting with
someone in the show constantly they're
fighting i thought
why not
address that in this moment i would have
liked that i think it would have been
great to see how they would have wrote
it and dealt with it because i'm sure
elliot page himself was involved in this
process because what else are they going
to do they can't just you know in the
show it was a woman you know what i mean
vanya this woman and all of a sudden
it's not anymore so you got to kind of
address it i kind of would have liked
them to address it and really get into
it like artistically but that's just the
artist in me i'm
i love drama the like i'm talking about
on screen i think that that's good
tension and drama and it really would
have they could have really went places
with it and i also understand why
the actor them was like you know what
i'm dealing with this in my real life
uh i don't want to deal with this at
work
um
in my fictional life
uh you know so
you know
i know what you mean though like i see
people in the in the chat saying like
they're glad they didn't make it a story
line but it was part of the story you
get what i'm saying
and i think that it would have just
added some extra tension that was
already there
like this character that elliot page is
playing is
super like eagle go my ego maniacal like
like the world revolves around me type
of thing and they were kind of
addressing that a little bit and i
thought that there were moments there
they could have brought this up to but
they didn't i'm fine with it um
i i think that
i like the show uh you know what i mean
um
i watched like it's like it's a good
watch you know i watched the whole
season while i was on vacation because i
was just like wow i'm already done with
this so you know i give it a few
woo-woos you know what i mean
you know so uh woo-woo's uh
um
umbrella academy and you know
elliott page on his journey uh
going through this process you know what
i mean that you know uh to me i think
it's too public you know it's like hey
do you like
i don't got all my [ __ ] out that i you
know what i mean that i
you know i mean i get it you know we're
in this weird times and society likes to
fight but i think this everything's so
polarizing that it's like oh my god you
know what i mean
so it's weird and speaking of that this
is the next thing i actually wanted to
talk about um
is is this is the same kind of it's in
that same line man
it's in that same vein
so
let's get into this one all right now
i want to reiterate what i said earlier
okay
me personally i don't care about your
issue these issues that they they keep
telling us and yelling at us that we're
supposed to care about you have to care
about these things and some of us are
just kind of like hey
it's like somewhat you know it's like
when somebody comes to you and they go
hey yo did you hear that so-and-so is
gay the response to that should always
be so like that's just where i'm at with
it but okay maybe you're not maybe this
is like
so important to you
what people are doing in the bedroom or
who they love all right
to me i think gayness is on a spectrum i
think it's just like autism in terms of
like you know they have a spectrum of
different
uh levels of like where you are with
this you know what i mean
and so whatever where are you super
straight or you're like you're
fluid or whatever the things you are i
don't care i think it's live your life
okay
that being said
so
there's this movie that came out buzz
lightyear the uh cartoon it's like an
origin story of the so in toy story so
in toy story you have
the buzz lightyear cart um action figure
and that in the car in toy story the
action figure is based off buzz
lightyear
in that world whoever this character is
so they're doing like an origin story of
here's buzz lightyear
uh and
are you gonna say it's very confusing
because you wonder why because tim allen
didn't do the voice but this is why he
didn't do the voice because tim allen
was the toy he wasn't buzz lightyear if
that makes sense
anyways so they did this movie buzz
lightyear
it didn't do very well in terms of for
pixar but there is a controversial thing
that happened in the movie that a lot of
people are talking about
and i want to talk about it
so in the movie there is a lesbian kiss
i even have it pulled up um
i i don't want to necessarily play it
because i don't want to get dinged but
here's the moment okay so they walk into
this thing
and they kiss okay
all right
so um
i
it's one of these things where you just
go
wait how do i feel about this
how am i supposed to feel if i talk
about it are you being homophobic or you
know that that's just where we're at
right now in the world where you might
see something on screen and be like hey
you know i didn't like this and then or
or i didn't like the movie or i didn't
like whatever and then people make you
feel like you know you're wrong because
uh you know what i mean
all right so i'm gonna tell you
but i feel like
my stance is like i said i don't care
you know but i also
have to think about like there are
people that do care and and people come
from different walks of life so here's
what i mean by that i don't have kids
but i want to have kids
hopefully you know honeymoon went well
if you know what i mean
because daddy put it in
anyway
let's say you have kids and let's say
you're actually open-minded person
you might be a thing was like you see
this because you see this and you go all
right whatever i don't care so you let's
say you the people that don't have kids
you just go to this the thing comes on
screen you go i don't you don't care now
me i'm all about artistic integrity so
and and like i am very like super i'm
hyper sensitive to like
this sort of like jamming things down
our throat
is this the only kiss in the movie
because if it's the only kiss in the
movie just
is other people kissing you know what i
mean and even in this scene right here
when you look at it you got a
interracial couple like look
look look look at this look at this so
in the back you got the black dude with
whoever she is if it's a white girl
latina i didn't see the movie so you
know i don't know what that's about
right there but even in there this whole
scene
is like an agenda going on right you're
like okay this is what you're trying to
do all right fine
i'm so super hyper aware of it because
i'm like where was this the whole movie
you know like i i don't like when these
kind of things happen because i go is
this
for the art or are you trying to
make a statement
uh or do you think your responsibility
is to make a statement with your art i
don't know and so
we live in a free country where i can
interpret this the way i want
and i'm saying
this is like why you put this in the
movie you know what i mean why
you know like
did this did this surface the movie like
is there other kissing going on in the
movie or is this the only kiss in the
movie you know what i mean because then
you just kind of go well if this is the
only kiss in the movie then you're doing
it to make a statement this is why you
did this
okay
i'm an adult i'm a grown ass man i can
go to the movie i can see this i mean
that's how i think i'll be like oh wow
what a scene you got the black guy
in the back the lesbian kiss it's like
okay all right get with you rkdisney
pixar i see what you're doing good for
you thumbs up person of color brother's
gay i get it i don't care
i also understand that there's another
side of this for people that do care
that's not coming from a hateful place
let's say you have kids if i had kids
and i took my kids to this and i didn't
know this was going on in this movie and
i haven't had to talk with my young kids
yet about
same-sex relationships
so we walking in the theater and i'm
thinking okay good now i have some like
some entertainment for my kids and we
could just get lights and pictures and
we could just get have two hours we're
not worried about nothing in the world
here comes the lesbian kiss
now your five six seven eight nine year
old is looking at you like hey why are
those two girls kissing
and now you have to have a discussion
that you weren't ready to have yet i
think it's fair for people to be like yo
can you give me a heads up on this
i i don't think that's being hateful i
don't think that's being like whatever
like
it's not normalized yet okay
in your household if it is good for you
then you don't have to worry about it
when you go into the theater and that
happens your kids might be like oh this
is just like auntie rose or oh this is
like our neighbor or like oh this is
what mom and dad had to talk to us about
that this kind of thing happens and it's
okay good good for that family i'm proud
of your progressiveness
but there are other people who haven't
made that choice yet who haven't decided
to talk to their young children about
other
alternatives in the world and things
that are going on or maybe things that
may be going on with them i think it's
okay for those parents to be like yo
what up pixar
you need to put this in the damn
you know you know how they do it on like
you watching a show on like hbo and now
they do it says smoking sexual activity
uh light strobe lights like you know
they put like a list of things that
might be going on in this movie sexual
you know uh rape they put all kinds of
things so you know you can go okay
here's all the things i might see in
this movie let me decide if i want to
watch a movie like this
god damn it i think you need to have
this kind of stuff with this for people
that have kids who have not decided
now if you feel if you're a person out
there that feels like well so what they
should talk about it i i don't disagree
with you but don't be mad if there's
people out there with kids who haven't
had that talk yet who are now forced to
i i don't think there's anything wrong
with that
now
i do find something wrong with the
people who are actually homophobic and
who are making a big stink and who are
you know it's like come on you don't
have to be so hateful there are people
that live like this in the world this
looks like people i know i've been to
parties like this i've actually been to
a party where there's interracial
couples and a lesbian couple kisses you
know what i'm saying like this is real
world right but like damn so let's take
a chill pill there's a middle of the
road right here where we can have a
discussion without somebody saying
you're homophobic or hateful and then
the other side too
chill out you know this is this is real
world stuff too and you you know you
need to be more accepting but either way
i think that there's a discussion to be
had
without it being such a
polarizing subject
[Music]
done i get into it on reference with
griffin
we get into it on river mcgriffin all
right i want to talk to you guys about
this other thing that i saw
uh
this one is funny to me okay speaking of
hateful
speech
so there's this
conservative white woman her name is
alison steinberg
she i don't know who she is i just saw a
tweet about it and i was looking at the
tweet and to me it was kind of funny and
so um
i'm gonna i'm gonna play i hope i think
you guys will be able to hear it let's
see
hello
wait let me refresh
refresh baby oh no
wait hold up let me find it again
yeah so she's like this like
she's this um
oh here we go tweet replies here it is
here it is she's this conservative like
i said white lady who i think the most
confused people right now species is
conservative white women i think that
they
can be like they sound
let me say this too i don't i also don't
like when like somebody tells you
because of like your race
or your gender that you're supposed to
follow
like this political party i hate that
you know
the democrat democratic
like the super lefty people
try to tell you this all the time that
latinos you should be
more you should all vote democrat and
it's like now man values are important
to certain people and like i think
because of the overturning of roe versus
wade the country is not going to be
divided more than just conservative
liberal it's really going to be about
rel it's like religion non-religious
people um wealthy non-wealthy i mean i
think that we're we're being divided in
more ways than just it can't just
simplify to democrat and republican or
conservative and liberal like far left
far right
that's the craziness but like this is
like okay let me see if i can play this
now
all right here we go
all right
what the hell is that
huntington beach is the town of good
old-fashioned hard-working american
people the people that work okay and
this is what i have an issue with
this part right here i think you guys
can hear it
all right let me go back to this part
this is the interesting part good
old-fashioned hard-working american
people
okay let me play that again
hard-working america is the town of good
old-fashioned hard-working american
people okay
this is my point of contention i have
with people like this
she said
first of all she has a problem with this
gay pride flag flying in hermosa beach
in orange county it's like
why
uh
like it's like okay
so
we're either either here nor there
good old-fashioned
hard-working american people
i have a i have an issue with the words
good old fashioned
old fashioned
my question to miss
allison whatever her name is
how far back do you want to go
for the good old-fashioned american
values
how far back do you want to go
because you want to go as far back as
when women weren't allowed to vote
or own things
or
you're not going to go back that far
when we you're going to go back to as
far as well we fixed that so uh we're
gonna go back as far as like where women
have equal rights and all that is that
how far you want to go back is that the
old-fashioned values
because i'm sure that there's
some white men
who
probably think
yeah i don't like that what is this
i don't think women should be being
allowed to do this you know what i mean
like how far back you want to go
because
the country was a certain way there was
slavery there was like women couldn't
vote women couldn't own things women
couldn't do a lot of stuff
you know i'm sure there's guys out there
who are like yeah let's get back to good
old-fashioned values so there was a
point where the values had to change
the the values had to change right
so is she starting her count from good
old-fashioned values at that point
because this gay pride flag is an
example of values changing
how far back so she wants to go
like as far as that so women should be
able to vote and do all that
and then that's when the values that's
when the country was right set right
you know what i mean like how far back
does she want to go
so it's like
when people are like hateful like this
it just sounds confusing to me she
sounds confused to me
you know you you don't like
i i and my thing too is just own it just
say you don't like gay people
you know what i mean like why why make
it about
like old-fashioned american values when
america has had fluctuating values since
the beginning
we started on terrible values so you
want to go back to like old american
values where it was like like what where
slavery were like you know the
constitution was like black people were
weren't even a full person like how far
back you want to go
i don't know this
crazy
you know what i mean
it's
i i just
i just feel like
why have this out
why why
put this out when you know how people
are gonna take it
you know
like like
the people that support you they already
support you the people that are anti-gay
the people that think this is like wrong
and all that they already they're
already with you on this so you put
something out like this is it just to
rile people up and make people feel a
certain way maybe who knows
i just i just questioned to her
i just questioned to her like
own your bigotry
and like how far back do you want to go
for your old-fashioned
values
how far you want to go like when does it
start like give me the date that the
old-fashioned values start
because i know
it's going to be
after women's rights
you know what i'm saying but maybe maybe
not for her maybe she's like and i'm
tired of women you know i don't know man
and this leads us into the last topic of
the day which is like as you guys know
the
the uh you know roe vs wave was
overturned you know
and i don't know man i
i have soldier i have such a nuanced
opinion of the thing i don't even even
want to go into that part of it
i just want to go like because
because here's the thing man we live in
a country
because like right now all the like all
the sort of like liberal progressive
people that i see on the internet some
of my friends they're posting these
things and it's all
democracy is you know
there's no more democracy democrat you
know
anytime your side loses
you think democracy is
it's done
when this actually is a process of
democracy
it's so nuanced man i could do a whole
episode on this and just really do if i
did like some more research on like how
all this works
but i found out some things you know
we're the only country in the world
where abortion was a constitutional
right the only country in the entire
world
so it doesn't mean that abortion can't
come back or like you know i mean
apparently congress can pass pass it but
how do we get congress we have to vote
man you got to vote you gotta vote for
your senators you gotta vote for your
congressman you gotta vote for your
governors most people aren't involved
most people don't vote the voting
numbers are super low all the time and
this is what you get this is what you
get
you know but just because your side lost
it doesn't mean democracy is under
attack in the same way those people
when biden won that was democracy and
play man you know these trials that are
going on for trump right now they're
showing they're proving that he was
trying to overturn the election that he
was doing some shady [ __ ] to try to stay
president
and the democracy the democratic system
won the democratic system was like now
you can't do that
and
he didn't win that's democracy but there
are people that think
that democracy oh my god trump didn't
win democracy is shattering and then
they tried to go do that thing they they
went to the capitol right
everybody thinks democracy is not
working when it's
not what they want
abortion this is another example of it
all right the states are gonna
pass their laws
uh you know this can still be
this could still
apparently from my understanding is
congress can still make this a law that
abortion is legal in all 50 states
it just doesn't have to be a
constitutional law you know what i'm
saying like that's this is so nuanced
man but don't think that democracy is
being shattered because this thing
happened you know there's ways to fight
it i mean they fought it they've been
working on it for years you know they
they elected their conservative people
religious conservative people to the
supreme court and they and they did it
you know uh okay in 50 more years
if the democrats can get their [ __ ]
together and start actually you know
voting and picking candidates that they
want and fighting for the stuff in the
right way in the courts in the you know
in the voting booth and maybe this will
change again but you know the world's
not coming to an end guys all right
it's like
so
i have a friend of mine
i was gonna show her thing but i'm not
gonna put her on blast
but like
so on her instagram so the first picture
on her instagram grid i'm looking at i'm
scrolling through
and the first
picture is like this thirst trap
two bikini picture
you know what i mean you slide and it's
i mean she's dope okay so it's super
dope sexy
the next one is
this roe vs wave and it's like it's it's
a viral video that's going around by
this um um
this talk show host i don't know she's
talked to whatever it was but i know
you've seen it maybe you've seen it
where she's talking about you know
i you know i'm i don't believe in your
bible uh i fight for your right to
believe in it but you can't force it on
me it's a really powerful
video okay and she has that on her thing
and then underneath it says and i see
this a lot and i've seen this i have a
bunch of female friends who are saying
this this is the sentiment they're
putting out where are the men on the
road versus wait where are you guys
where are you
what are you guys you know what
and then i want to respond to that
so to my friend you know where we are
we're on your other picture we're on the
bikini picture that's where we are if
you want to know where we are you want
to know where the men are they're on the
supreme court [ __ ] [ __ ] up
and ruling the world
[Music]
oh and winning
women's swim meets
that's where the men are you know where
the men are like stop asking about where
the men are
we've done enough damage
where are you
that's what i want to know where are you
i'm going to tell you guys a story
why i stopped drinking milk
i don't drink cow milk anymore like
regular dairy
and
i remember i i rarely do i mean
sometimes i'm at a restaurant they don't
have i go okay give me a little cream
but for the most part i don't drink milk
anymore and i'm gonna tell you
i remember
the day
i stopped drinking milk
um
i was watching face it was facebook a
facebook video came up and it was just
like dope she was a bad [ __ ] okay she
was dope it was one of those like i'm
like oh [ __ ]
you know you like let me see what this
video is about
and she was like super she was a very
provocative at first and then you know
and the way she was doing it was great
because she was still being sexy but she
was like do you know how milk is made
and then cut two she starts going in
and like showing like
milk farms and starts talking about it
and it really was a powerful and
effective for me
so by the end of it i was like oh you
got me you tricked me
you tricked me and it actually worked
because
after that i was like oof i don't know
if i can drink milk anymore
you know what i mean i was just like so
i'm saying
stop asking like
what i think about what's going on just
do your part
you know so maybe on that
bikini picture
maybe you put the name of the congress
person that we should vote for in the
next election right underneath right
underneath there you know what i mean
you really want to use your powers for
good
you know what i mean like i don't know
do your part too i just
because i'm i'm i'm a belief that like
you know what the beauty of this system
that we have in the united states is
that we don't have
like all these laws that are like super
universal that the states are
they leave it up to the states and look
we have different value systems all over
the country people that live on coastal
cities and urban centers they have
different values from people that live
in like middle of america stuff so it's
like you you have a place you can live
anywhere in the united states
that are more in line with how you
believe
and so yes they overturn roe vs weight
in the constitution but it doesn't mean
that abortion is going to go away
altogether you know i mean like i say
i've talked about what i feel about that
i i'm not a super fan of that
but i was i i
am a fan of a woman's right to choose
i i do believe in that and i just get
sick and tired of like people trying to
justify it
like all the i see women saying that
like oh abortion is good and i'm like
what like don't say that
you know like i don't i don't agree with
that i don't think it's good but i
you making the choice to me it's like
it's like putting down a horse you know
it's like it's not good
you have to make this choice because of
whatever the circumstances are whatever
whether they're good or bad boom but
you're not having a good time doing it
you know you're just like so stop like
trying to justify it and making it out
like this is some great thing
like we're talking about a thing that is
that like a majority of people don't
think it's great but
we're saying we know you have to do this
sometimes you know you're making a
choice and i don't even care about the
people that want to justify why like all
these like extreme cases of like well a
ten-year-old girl was raped so that's
when i'm okay with abortion or there's
something going on in utero that if the
mom's gonna die so like i don't need all
the justifications
i don't need all that to say i just say
i respect your right to choose but
don't but let's not sit here and act
like it's a great choice i've said this
before i don't want to go into it again
but i will say this in closing until
we get a handle on what's going on
hey everybody
maybe take some personal responsibility
now
you know all the people that are using
it as like a you know
you know like a birth control you know
what i mean like let's maybe you know
get your pull-out game in order maybe
use some condoms
maybe we should really you should really
think about what this means now before
you like it i know how i know what it
look we all want to bust inside
okay let's just
that's just the crass way to say it i
know how good that feels but now we need
to like
let's think about this a little bit more
now where am i is this a good place to
do this am i in a good state to do this
just in case i think i think that like
taking a time taking a second now before
we just willy-nilly
until we get a handle on this okay
uh just
just uh
you know
take some time y'all i just i don't you
know cause we don't know what's gonna
happen next
and like i say i you know
i i think
a woman's right to choose is super
important it's their body like i get
what's happening but it's like come on
until we get some science where we could
do it in like a
a machine or something you know what i
mean until it's like you know
that's what they need to start working
on like it's like well i'm about to have
a baby take it out and put it in this
thing so i don't have to worry about it
until we get until we got that going on
until technology's more
you know because
again i don't want to keep going so now
i'm just rambling but
um
you know they are talking about other
things now they're talking about
overturning you know not over you know
they want to get rid of gay rights and
they want to
some places they're talking about like
they don't even want women to get
contraceptive contraceptives like you
know birth control so like
i think that's going way too far
you know what i mean but that's why get
involved guys that's what i'm gonna
close with it's like get involved vote
some people say they think voting
doesn't work help i it does
because it's on like a more nuanced
level like you really have to look at
how it really works in terms of like
when you vote for your senators when you
vote for your congressman like so you
hear about these um these like
representatives who are like
playing to their base
you know
we don't the the other side they don't
they're not playing to their base
because their base ain't even voting or
not even getting out there so if you
really want to make a difference
i think that should be the outcry
it's you know not sentiment on the
internet
but actual action
mkels
you are acknowledged
sorry thank you for the super chat all
you guys thank you for the super chats
thank you for being here
um
somebody asked a question so what's the
difference between abortion and birth
control i mean if you
you can answer that question dude come
are
on
really you don't know the difference i
mean there's a huge difference but like
i say they're
i don't know it's a it's a real
discussion that we're going to continue
to have to have
but we should have it but what i'm
saying let me let me close with this the
world is not ending
so my liberal progressive people the
world is not ending this is still
something that could be passed in
congress you know in the same way like
weed man like weed was legal in a bunch
of states but it wasn't legal federally
yet so you know it's like you could they
could do that they could they could
like i
i don't want to i don't want to speak
too much because i don't want to speak
out my ass too much because it's like i
have to like look some of this stuff up
but i do know
that laws can be passed by congress
that are that doesn't necessarily have
to be constant constitutional laws
you know what i mean something like that
so anyway in the comments if you want to
write in the comments let's write about
it let's let's you know let's let's we
can fact check and we can like get this
all out there but you know this is just
a look look i'm just comedian talking
i'm just having a discussion and i want
you to talk about it too we don't have
to be hateful you don't have to be like
we're just trying to have a discourse
and that's what we should do so talk
about things for real don't let make
people make you feel like don't let make
don't let people put you in a box so if
you're talking about stuff like say that
kiss on that movie don't make
people make you feel like what that
means you're homophobic no man you just
want to have a discussion about things
and i think how i talked about it is a
fair thing i think it's fair to feel
that way if you're a parent and you feel
that way that's fair
so anyways
whoo
um it's time for some zone i gotta go
play me some warzone y'all
i love y'all
this is just one of those episodes
of riffing with griffin
shout out to you guys thanks for all the
super chats thanks for the love thanks
for being here every week
spread the word um
you know we're gonna keep going see what
we're doing check out king and this
thing and also check out jen the gen my
other podcast is going strong man i'm
having a good time with matthew espinoza
and i
talking about different things from the
different generations so check that out
too king sting wing and the sing
and jen to jen podcast so please take a
look gander and listen about that thank
you for listening on all the the
platforms and thank you for watching
here on youtube uh i look at the
comments because i like having a good
back and forth just you know you don't
gotta be hateful guys just let's just uh
you know
you know let's just talk all right so
thanks for being here see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you